wolverine first he writes my cottails with the
r rating then the hairy mother of the anning by
dying what guess what wolvine i'm dying in this one too to
understand why i took a cat nap on 1200 gallons of
high chest fuel i need to take you back to the
dewey slopes six weeks ago i got international
taking out mass murderers gangsters unspeakable
criminals people no one would even touch except me
i'm gonna touch them all over and then he uh
jumps in and goes hey it's gail calling i love
this shiny suit it really brings out this in your
eyes he goes whatever you're paying i'll double it
in chinese i don't speak cantonese mister oh i'm
not even gonna attempt that but i do think eighth
grade spanish so donde esta la biblioteca which
literally translates to i don't bargain falcon
then he jumps through the whole
window and stuff and he goes oh
oh this isn't gilbert's i am so sorry i thought
this was and then he jumps behind the camera
oh hello i know right
Welcome back everyone happy new year ryan reynolds
blessing us with new deadpool in 2021 ringing in
the new year there's a whole bunch of deadpool
stuff that's actually happening now behind the
scenes at marvel so it's actually starting to spin
up in a really exciting way so we'll break it down
2021 already looking so much better than 2020
so be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i will be doing deadpool videos throughout the
year as we learn more about what's going on with
him in the mcu now we finally have a window when
they're actually going to release deadpool 3.
but if you have no idea what's going on with this
while he's with this kid doing this big deadpool
monologue he's actually working on another
movie right now called the atom project with
this actor who's doing this deadpool monologue
a full deadpool monologue gripping on wolverine
and dropping enough curse words that they had to
edit it out keep in mind this is a super young
kid and he totally crushed that deadpool
scene that he's doing with ryan reynolds
so this is just him doing more classic ryan
reynolds stuff dropping funny deadpool videos
throughout the year while they're also working on
a bunch of other movies like he's got a billion
movies that he's working on the next couple of
years while deadpool 3 is happening behind the
scenes for the past couple of years he's been
talking about the mcu deadpool 3 kevin feige it
seems like it's been a million years at this point
just because 2020 drug on for so long but really
all the deadpool 3 news started the minute the
fox disney deal was announced way back in 2017.
even as deadpool 2 was just coming out in theaters
we had heard that there was going to be a fox
disney deal and that's when people started to talk
about deadpool in the mcu in what that would look
like but it really wasn't till 2019 after avengers
end game came out in theaters that's around the
time that the fox disney deal actually closed
through the government they approved it and they
got all those characters back officially that's
when kevin feige was allowed to start hiring
people to actually write the new fantastic four
movie the new x-men reboot movies that they said
that they're doing and the new deadpool 3 movie
that's why for the past year or so every time
you see him appear on a talk show or appear with
hugh jackman doing wolverine x-men stuff they did
a bunch of those during 2020 it's just him hyping
up deadpool continuing in the mcu while continuing
to take shots at himself and hugh jackman as they
continue to do their other projects on the side
that's why you see him posting all those
videos together because they have a bunch
of side projects and charities that they do
and they use their funny deadpool wolverine
in their real-life relationship to just hype
that up hands down my favorite one though was
the wolverine origins joke that they did that
fell apart quickly this is just you and me logan
i guess so you know you know what that makes
this a reunion for x-men origins reunite
yeah leave schreiber is so funny that wolverine
origins team reunite but the big thing that just
happened a little while ago is marvel finally
officially announced deadpool 3 they officially
hired writers and they'll announce a director
soon too probably before the end of this year
originally i wanted taika watiti to do it because
he expressed an interest in the deadpool character
he said he was a huge fan but then they announced
thor 4 love and thunder and they now steve was
doing a star wars movie after that so he is
way too busy to do a deadpool movie right now
but they did confirm that deadpool 3 will be rated
r so don't freak out about that they're not going
to try and shoehorn him into a pg-13 rating just
because they want him to be in the mcu if you
didn't know or you hadn't realized before there's
kind of this unspoken or softly spoken rule at
disney that all the mainstream marvel films have
to be pg-13 just because of the way they market it
and the way it all works together they inherited
some rated r movies now because they own the fox
movies technically but they're actually going to
create an adult section for disney plus where a
lot of that's going to live so eventually you
will see all the deadpool movies on disney plus
but they already confirmed that deadpool is an mcu
character and he's going to cross over into future
regular mainstream mcu movies like avengers 5 the
future x-men reboot movies once they get ready
with that franchise other people's movies as well
too like hopefully doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness because supposedly as part of all the
talks with deadpool 3 they're also negotiating
a special contract for ryan reynolds that will
keep him playing deadpool for a long time but
instead of doing a billion more r-rated deadpool
solo movies after deadpool 3 because disney's not
super comfortable doing that they'll use deadpool
more like a supercharged version of stan lee
with all the cameos in different marvel movies
like deadpool will do a ton of crossover movies
and smaller funny cameo scenes in movies where
it makes sense that he'd show up they kind of
had to do the same thing with the hulk for the
last several years for completely different
reasons though but hulk did get an arc in the
marvel movies it's just broken up across a bunch
of different avengers movies so going forward
deadpool is going to be like a hardcore version
of stan lee in the mcu commenting on all the
action pointing out things taking shots at people
like there's always things in marvel movies that
just don't work real well or jokes that don't land
you bring in deadpool so that you can make fun
of that kind of stuff think about the way he
made fun of all the other fox x-men movies he'll
do the exact same thing for all the marvel movies
making references and commentary about avengers
infinity war the snap iron man dying making fun
of robert downey jr in real life making fun of
chris evans for retiring as captain america like
deadpool making old man cap jokes jokes about
how the mcu is over and the hype is dead after
avengers end game just taking shots at everyone
in the mcu including the actors and people like
kevin feige kevin feige is also an easter egg in
the first deadpool movie in the pizza box if you
were ever going to make kevin feige a canonical
mcu character you would do it in a deadpool movie
but the way they're going to handle deadpool
3 being rated r but also kind of wanting to
tie him to the mcu is they'll do something like
they did during spider-man far from home in that
opening scene that funny slideshow montage with
all the dead characters something funny like that
where they used their images they referenced the
characters but like iron man himself didn't appear
on screen during spider-man far from home black
widow didn't appear during spider-man far from
home so deadpool can still do a bunch of mcu
and avengers stuff in his deadpool solo movies
it's just they have to be really careful about the
way they reference that stuff so that it all makes
sense as for the actual story of deadpool 3 a lot
of that will just address how he's going to be
coexisting with the mcu characters going forward
without totally selling out or bastardizing the
character they also said that they had to cut a
ton of disney jokes at a deadpool too like ryan
reynolds joking about getting melted into a disney
liquid for making jokes that they didn't like
but it was actually the fox people that made them
take all those disney jokes out because they were
afraid that it would hurt the buyout deal because
that was all going on while they were still making
deadpool too so they're like please don't make fun
of disney too much we don't want to tank this deal
now it sounds like from what the disney ceo has
said about deadpool being such a huge fan of that
character in kevin feige it sounds like they're
totally cool with ryan reynolds taking shots at
anyone or anything that he wants to my favorite
pick just in terms of comic book stories for them
to adapt for the movie that would actually be
really timely and apropos of mcu deadpool now
because so much is happening with the multiverse
would be deadpool kills the marvel universe
except you do it as deadpool kills the fox marvel
universe because obviously they have to address
all that continuity and clearly it's probably
going to be a multiverse explainer but that's
how you do deadpool kills the marvel universe
and they just use it as an opportunity to clean
up the timelines like he said he was doing in
the deadpool 2 post-credits scene like take that
concept and do the maximum effort version of that
for an entire movie and with all the multiverse
and time travel happening during marvel phase 4
movies in disney plus series villains like kang
the conqueror showing up in the loki series
in ant-man 3 it also feels like that kind of
story fits real well with where they're taking
the mcu right now before avengers 5 picks up
then because they already confirmed that deadpool
will be in the future mcu movies crossing over
you put him legit in avengers 5 and that's where
you actually see him interacting with a lot of
the other characters in a big way but because they
haven't hired a director yet and it takes a while
to turn a movie around the earliest they'll
probably be able to get deadpool 3 released
will be 2023 let me know in the comments though
which other movies do you think the deadpool will
show up in first obviously right now the top
pick is doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
just a real small cameo scene just to
let us know that he's out on the horizon
while you wait for everything click here
for that brand new marvel fantastic four
teaser video and click here to watch
tom holland reacting to spider-man 3
in venom crossover thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe maximum effort!